un quart d'heure pour faire sa valise et
emportèrent avec soin le principal c'est
le temps accordé à catia pour quitter au
plus vite sa maison son mari a été
blessé par un obus alors qu'il allait
chercher de l'eau le couple alors décidé
que cette fois ci il fallait sont allés
et non pas dimanche nous sommes
conscients qu'il n'y aura pas de fin
heureuse ici après que l'obus a atterri
devant notre cour hier nous avons perdu
tout espoir de nous échapper sans aide
la famille est évacuée de la ville de
l'itie de chance grâce à ce groupe de
bénévoles ukrainien depuis deux mois
anton n'y a rien de choquer son équipe
frappe aux portes avec l'objectif de
sauver les civils des bombes ce jour là
le danger est particulièrement proche
les russes se trouvent à moins de trois
kilomètres de l'iscid chance que
quelque chose vient de tomber très près
nous allons les voir ce qu'il en est en
ville mais ça n'a pas arrêté de tomber
de la journée donc toute cette zone est
très dangereuse leur mission se poursuit
d'un bout à l'autre de la ville sacha
victime d'une attaque cérébrale n'a reçu
aucune aide médicale depuis cinq jours
il va enfin pouvoir quitter l'horreur de
l'itie chang
niveau et sept autres
avant la guerre cent mille personnes
vivaient à l'issue de chances que
environ 8000 serait encore sur place
selon les autorités locales ah non
monsieur je pense je suis sûre même que
des civils seront laissés pour compte il
y aura des combats de rues ici pendant
des semaines peut-être et même des mois
évidemment ces gens ne devraient pas
rester mais ils le feront et beaucoup
d'entre eux mourront nous resterons dans
des conditions horribles très longtemps
après des semaines de combats les russes
et leurs alliés ont conquis presque
toute la ville voisine de severodonetsk
elle cherche désormais à encercler la
zone et revendiquer la conquête de toute
la région de lougansk